karine rosinski de karine rosinski
madame
[Musique]
je te faire donc je trouve 18 tu crois
quoi sert alors depuis qu elle est
parfaite chevaux lundi quatre jours
d'absence soit vous inquiétez pas
pourquoi tu pars comme ça vous voulez
quoi nous éviter les mauvaises
rencontres comme un père le ferai
le cas d'asthme bonjour l'efs j'aurais
pu jouer tu le connais doux maman sur un
super sic au maximum qui transportait
s'est jamais affolé peut-être c'est quoi
ça vient d'où enfin kiss à partir des
gens ils sont noirs
vous la boîte à gants
non
ce demi tour c'est oublier ressemblent
pas l'afrique je suis connue oui
ce qui se passe au lit d'abord c'est
quoi ce bordel
sanogo tous bords
effectuer
jean l'herm ce qui m'importe quoi c'est
ma femme monte papier
vous trompez c'est pas elle
non